mobile task force edna 84 also known by
the code name and thus upon his crucible
is on one of the strangest missions
they've ever been sent on they sit in a
darkened room beads of sweat trickling
down their brows the lights of computer
monitors shine upon their faces they're
tackling a monster that if it escapes
will literally devour all of creation it
has no fear it has no remorse and if it
isn't kept contained by edna 84 it may
escape and wreak havoc across the world
oh and did we mention it's trapped in a
minecraft server you heard us right
scp-4335
is a cognitohazardous extra-dimensional
being of pure terror trapped inside a
procedurally generated world in the
immensely popular game minecraft you
hear about a lot of horrifying monsters
being described as lovecraftian but only
this monster is
minecraftian there's a lot that needs
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps this truly exceptional
piece contained the foundation first
discovered
scp-4335 back in 2010 shortly after the
alpha version of minecraft was released
because of the online nature of the game
it's proven to be impossible to contain
4335 externally seeing as it isn't
confined to any one physical location
shutting off the server 4335 is found in
is not an effective containment method
either as this just causes the entity to
simply hop to a different server the
foundation's greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of
minecraft and cause chaos in our world
that's why it's imperative to draft
containment procedures for
scp-4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site m1 the first official
foundation site made entirely out of
minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and anesthetized since then
elite scp foundation containment
specialists and gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for
scp-4335 site m1 is a large stone
complex built into the side of a
mountain it has a number of key features
including a supply area filled with
materials vital for 4335's continued
containment chests filled with books
that contain
scp-4335's containment procedures a few
animal farms for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about 4335
if they ever breach containment and
enter the server and of course the
actual containment chamber for
scp-4335 itself which is a little more
complicated 4335's containment chamber
is built out of several layers all made
from iron blocks the outermost cube is
75 by 75 by 75 blocks the inner cube is
55 by 55 by 55 blocks and the innermost
cube is 25 by 25 by 25 blocks creating
several levels of defense finally one
layer within all these others which
contains the anomaly proper is made from
obsidian blocks
scp-4335 is bound into the center of the
containment chamber with a complex
mechanism the outermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to scp-4335
there are even contingency measures for
if
scp-4335 manages to breach containment
if escape is attempted blocks of tnt
detonate above the ceiling causing lava
to pour into the chamber at that point
mtf edna 84 dispatched into the server
to lure 4335 back into its containment
chamber to do this they fire a mix of
fire resistant potions and ender pearls
which have teleportation capabilities
interestingly there's one more basic
method of luring
scp-4335 back into the obsidian cube
taunting and insulting one of
scp-4335's many anomalous abilities is
being able to hear people through the
screen and being a proud creature it
often responds to insults by charging in
to directly engage the insulter if
scp-4335 still manages to breach the
containment that has been set up for it
then they even expect that it will
likely soon hop into another server at
that point the goal will shift to
finding the monster and recontaining it
with containment procedures this complex
and extensive it shouldn't come as a
surprise that scp-4335
rests firmly in the ketter class what
exactly is this anomalous entity why
does its containment hinge on constantly
providing it with items and how did it
end up in mojang's popular building and
survival game in the first place
scp-4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all-black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular creepypasta figures
herobrine and the slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling
scp-4335 is an extremely delicate
process if command blocks creative mode
or server commands are ever enabled in a
server with scp-43
the server will instantly shut down and
scp-4335 will move to a different server
scp-4335 also uses its tendrils to
destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption scp-4335
grows and when it reaches sufficient
size it hops to a different server as
you can see keeping
scp-4335 contained as an uphill battle
but luckily there are two factors on the
foundation's side here the first is that
scp-4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively escape foundation forces the
second factor is that
scp-4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow
meaning if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the
entirety of the foundation's containment
procedures around
scp-4335 it's locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when
scp-4335 begins to grow
the foundation also found that the
application of ender pearls helps reduce
it back to its normal size however
scp-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors 4335 is a
virgin-class multi-sensory cognito
hazard anyone viewing it without proper
training and protection may experience
distressing hallucinations scp-4335
is also capable of telepathic speech
with people playing on its server and as
we alluded to earlier it can also hear
any noises you make while playing weird
is a term thrown around a lot when it
comes to scps considering it's pretty
much a requirement for the foundation to
take interest in you but an
all-devouring minecraft demon that can
hear you talking through your screen is
strange even by foundation standards mtf
edna 84 first discovered
scp-4335 and the single-player server of
minecraft user leaking heart three team
members jason yelsen richard duchamp and
chilia freemason covertly entered the
game to investigate and potentially
apprehend the creature when leaking
heart first discovered their presence on
what he thought was a private server he
quickly left a little creeped out by the
sudden intrusion thankfully the trio was
still able to locate scp-4335
they discovered the creature hiding
inside a giant crater as though it had
impacted the earth at considerable speed
richard duchamp who was the leader of
the team at the time made the mistake of
looking directly at the entity in that
moment he experienced the full force of
scp-43
cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes in the
aftermath of this incident duchamp was
taken off the case and jason yelsen was
promoted to head of the project things
were still going to get stranger yelsin
was able to open a dialogue with the
creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and yelsen
informed him that it's somehow fallen
into the world of minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this the entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server yelsen and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of
scp-4335 they weren't hurt but they did
appear strange and incoherent after
experiencing 4335's cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment
4335 was contained shortly thereafter
once again yelsin came face to face with
his new foe eight months after being
captured 4335 granted yeltsin another
interview from containment
4335 admitted that it almost respected
yeltsin and the rest of the foundation
for figuring out how to capture and
contain it so quickly in exchange it
would give the foundation something
extremely valuable information first it
asked one question of yelsin how does he
define creation joseon replied uh
something that is built and brought into
this universe by a sapient being using
other things from this universe
4335 agreed it went on to explain that
it came from a universe devoid of
creation a dark and unknowable place
filled with nothing but violent random
chaos its dimension existed directly
above ours and it often looked down at
us through a dimensional window
fascinated by all the creation below it
plotted and dreamed to one day
infiltrate our reality and yelsin
finally had the opportunity to ask the
magic question why
though he wasn't quite ready for the
brutal honesty of
scp-4335's reply i do not like to lie so
i will tell you now
i wish to suck it dry if the toys of
whatever force controls your universe
destroy the light destroy the earth and
destroy humanity
it reminded me
of me
a blubbering mass of intelligence and
order it seconds me in ways i cannot
comprehend
i hope you understand
scp-4335 was a connoisseur of creation
and it sought to devour all of it in
this moment yelsen realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
minecraft instead of our world which
appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but yelsin didn't have time to think
4335 was about to stage another daring
escape attempt one of its tendrils
reached out and attacked yeltsin's
player character in that moment the
real-life yeltsin began to hallucinate
and panic suddenly back in the game a
series of abnormally tall slender black
figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber
around scp-4335
it had somehow summoned new minions into
the game to assist in this containment
breach jason yelsen entered cognito
hazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own games the foundation managed to find
a solution they contacted mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
endermen and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for scp-4335
but there's only one question left why
did the entity fall into minecraft
rather than our world the file posits
the most likely answer because 4335
defines creation as elements made by
sapient beings in minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335's power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in
scp-4335's extra-dimensional eyes there
is no creation no intelligent design no
soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic randomness which is
too unlike its own dimension so even if
scp-4335 ever did arrive in our reality
we would likely be disappointed by how
little there is to eat now check out
scp-3082
neverland's lost boys and girls and
scp-3008 trapped in ikea for more
fascinating and strange locations from
the world of the scp foundation